esteemed Nobel laureates ladies and
gentlemen friends you are all most
welcome this morning to Stockholm on
behalf of the Nobel foundation and Nobel
media it's a great pleasure for me to
welcome you all to this year's Nobel
week dialogue with the theme your plate
our planet the Nobel week dialogue
started in 2012 as a day of lectures and
panels discussions schedule for the day
before the Nobel day our objective is to
create a series of thought-provoking
sessions and working groups on a topical
science-related theme this will be a day
filled with filled with stimulating
discussions about the future of food
bringing together distinguished
laureates leading scientists and expert
key opinion leaders policymakers and all
other interested parties not least many
students only online as well as on site
here in stock up the meeting is free and
is open and it's available for everyone
in the whole world with Nobel week
dialogue we aim to deepen the dialogue
between the scientific community and the
rest of society something which is
deeply needed today on issues that are
important to the world often with strong
connections to the Nobel Prize with
Nobel week dialogue science meets
society the real week dialogue is also
an important part of activities that we
have been developing over the last 20
years to inspire learning reflection and
innovation in the spirit of the Nobel
Prize interest in taking part in the
world represented by the Nobel prizes
huge to meet a growing thirst for
knowledge and curiosity northeast among
young people we are very pleased that
the new noble center is about to take
shape here install
will be a place for telling the
fascinating stories about the Nobel
laureates and their discoveries but it
will also be a global platform for a for
education for knowledge for critical
thinking at its heart where the major
challenges of tomorrow and today will be
discussed here we will develop content
that we believe will conquer the whole
world it will be our base camp it is my
strong hope and belief that within a few
years we will be able to arrange
meetings and many meetings of the kind
of the Nobel week dialogue in the Nobel
scepter I am among those who grew up
during the optimistic 1950s when when
everything was possible to boy like me
in idyllic Sweden which had been spared
the last two wars the world could only
get better for a long time it actually
also did living standards improved
education spread to more and more people
while science and research made major
breakthroughs of course not everything
was rosy we lived under the threat of a
nuclear war which was much more present
than it is today and in everybody in in
in the memories of everybody in my
generation the Cuban Missile Crisis in
the early sixties is as clear as 911 but
when the berlin wall fell fetch the
meanest diminished while democracy
spread the new countries like china
opened up economically prosperity groove
and fewer people went hungry many many
things went right for a decade or so
today things are different really
different tensions have increased again
in various ways while living standards
have increased for many people in
developing countries in the rich
countries large groups have indeed
fallen behind both new and old
democracies have proved fair
much more fragile than most of us
thought we also fake-face global
challenges climate change growing
terrorists and wars in far too many
places around the world with horrible
consequences in the form of deaths
famine and enormous refugee flows also
we are seeing how bored cross-border
cooperation and transparency are being
criticized and our science and research
for knowledge is being questions well
even facts or requested know or refuted
times at again leading politicians are
gaining support by appealing to people's
worst sites in times like this the Nobel
Prize is of vital importance more vital
importance I think than it has ever been
at least during my life type Alfred
Nobel knew that good role models people
and organizations can show that it's
possible to understand the world and to
improve the world not least and that we
can take on the biggest challenges on
our era and move forward that was very
much the idea behind this price today
our dialogue is about the global food
supply and the challenge is it is
associated with your plate our planet
although poverty has decreased as i said
before hunger is far from eliminated how
will we be able to feed 9 billion people
that we will soon be what does healthy
eating mean and what role does meals
play in our lives what will technology
put on our plates in the future what
does all this imply for an
environmentally in the end for the world
for the earth we will touch upon what
each of us can do what responsibilities
we as individuals have but also or what
kind of political solution the world
needs and how we can join forces to make
them a reality dear Nobel laureates
ladies and gentlemen friends I'm sure
that this will be a fascinating and
important day the previous Nobel week
dialogues that we've had in stockman
gothenburg has certainly turned out that
way thank you for listening and once
again you're all most welcome to Nobel
week dialogue thank
[Applause]